I'm going to talk about semacell as part of a frontline approach to diffuse large B-cell
lymphoma patients who are likely to relapse.
These are my disclosures.
So for patients with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, most patients achieve a response
after frontline immunochemotherapy approaches.
And of those patients, approximately two-thirds maintained long-term remissions or cures,
and about a third of patients relapse.
Currently, our standard of care in terms of monitoring those patients is, for the most
part, a watch and wait approach.
Sometimes we do surveillance imaging in follow-up.
Some of us don't do that.
And the question is, if we could identify these patients who are going to relapse earlier,
would they have a better outcome?
I think it's really interesting that about 15% of patients get CAR-T-cells in second-line
treatment.
So the number is actually low.
And one of the reasons.
For that, it's a lot of patients, when they progress, they have advanced disease, they
have extranodal disease that might exclude them from some of these therapies.
So the question of this study is, we know that MRD at the end of therapy is predictive
of outcome.
And if you are MRD positive, but you have a CR or PR, if you get soma cell, is that
associated with an improved EFS over observation?
So we know that MRD detection by ctDNA is a promising method for early relapse prediction
in large B-cell lymphoma.
And a lot of this work was done by Wyndham and Ash.
We know that in the interim setting, at the end of therapy, that if you're MRD positive
and you have large B-cell lymphoma, that this is associated with a worse event-free
survival.
And if we compare MRD to PET, the diagnostic threshold for ctDNA is lower than for PET,
as shown here.
And this is potentially very important in patients who relapse, if you can detect a
relapse earlier rather than later.
And there are a number of different ways of looking at ctDNA, and one of those is a phase-seq
assay.
And this is the test that is used in the study.
It's the foresight clarity test.
And there was a recent prospective multicenter validation study that looked at patients treated
in the frontline setting with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma and compared the predictive
value of end-of-therapy PET to end-of-therapy ctDNA.
And you can see here, if you look at progression-free survival, the PET positive patients are, you
can see here, on the lower curve and negative around the upper curve, and likewise with
ctDNA.
But you can see that ctDNA is more sensitive in predicting progression than PET.
So are we in the process of changing the paradigm of how we approach potential relapse patients
with large B-cell lymphoma?
And should we be using ctDNA?
To guide early intervention, MRD predicts risk of relapse as shown here.
And if you look at the disease burden of patients who relapse clinically by clinical presentation
or by imaging versus those who are positive by end-of-therapy MRD and are in CRPR, their
disease burden is much, much lower.
At the end of therapy, and in large-cell therapeutics, we know certainly in the frontline setting
that if you have lower burden disease, you have a better outcome.
So the drug that is being investigated is Semacel.
It's an anti-CD19 allogeneic CAR-T cell.
And one of the advantages, of course, of this is that it can be given to patients very quickly.
It's derived from healthy donors, but patients can potentially have immediate access to cell therapy
that is allogeneic versus autologous, which takes some time to produce.
So the product has been tested in the relapsed refractory setting in patients,
principally with diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, but also with other B-cell lymphomas.
And this was published last year.
And in terms of efficacy, Semacel was associated with an overall response rate of 58%
with 42% of patients achieving a CR.
And if you look at the duration of responses and the duration of CRs, they're shown here.
And they are, I think it's fair to say, similar to autologous CAR-T cell results.
Also, in terms of safety, in the relapsed refractory setting,
the product was safe.
If you look at CRS and ICANS and graft-versus-host disease,
these were very low throughout the study and at the selected Phase II dose.
So the current Alpha-3 Phase II design is shown here.
So patients have a new diagnosis of large B-cell lymphoma, including diffuse large B-cell lymphoma,
high-grade B-cell lymphoma, and primary mediastinal B-cell lymphoma.
And at the end of immunochemotherapy, they are safe.
And if they are in remission by endotherapy PET with a CR or a PR,
and if they are MRD positive, then they're randomized to either get lymphodepletion chemotherapy
and Semacel or observation.
Study is divided into two parts, Part A and Part B.
Part A is currently being analyzed at the moment.
So there's an interim of safety and biomarker-based futility analysis ongoing.
And Part B of the study has started.
And I've talked about the eligibility in terms of large B-cell lymphoma subtypes.
The study is ongoing throughout various centers.
So in conclusion, the Alpha-3 study is looking at large B-cell lymphoma patients that are in CR or PR.
And the question is if you are and you are MRD positive, is intervening with this agent,
is it associated with a better survival compared to observation?
And we'll have a discussion and questions later.
Thank you.